adressée à monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
monsieur le ministre
hier après midi le débat en séance a
porté sur la place déclinante de notre
agriculture dans les marchés
internationaux
aujourd'hui après une forte des prises
qui n'est pas d'aujourd'hui
notre agriculture n'occupe plus que 50%
de la superficie de notre territoire
depuis plus de trois ans une majorité de
nos agriculteurs désespère leurs revenus
et de plus en plus bas voire quelquefois
inexistant avec des moyennes de revenus
de 500 euros par mois ce qui sont la
règle
la loi galim présenter hâtivement comme
une solution n'est qu'une déception
supplémentaire pour le monde agricole
le sénat l'avait prédit et toutes ces
propositions avaient été rejetées la
sécheresse qui sévit dans certaines
régions ne fait qu'aggraver la situation
les jeunes sont toujours plus endettés
les moins jeunes sont gagnés par le
désespoir
malgré un engagement de passion et
personnels de tous les jours certains
d'entre eux confrontés une immense
détresse mettent fin à leur existence et
plongent leurs familles dans le deuil
quel drame humain que dirait ton d'une
catastrophe qui chaque année ferait plus
de 300 victimes
monsieur le ministre quelles
dispositions comptez vous prendre pour
enrayer cette terrible hémorragie
quelles mesures structurelles
quelles mesures conjoncturelles
l'agriculture at-elle encore pour le
gouvernement un avenir dans notre pays
pour voir